subscribe
Hallihallo!
Und was gibt es Neues Leute?
Leute ich hab heute ein Angebot gesehen und zwar von irgendeinem Werbeartikelladen, der druckt FFP2-Masken mit Custom-Motiven.
Und da dachte ich mir, ich bestell eine mit Keks drauf, dann kann ich Facecam machen und es erkennt mich keiner.
Und man erkennt aber trotzdem, dass ich das bin.
Wie lief eigentlich das Vorstellungsgespräch? Recht gut.
Ich hab heute nochmal mit denen telefoniert und in den nächsten paar Tagen, Wochen gucke ich da mal hin und gucke mir das an.
Ich kann mal gucken ob man sich da versteht und wenn das alles passt und nicht noch von den anderen Sachen was dazwischen kommt, dann werde ich da unterschreiben.
Hast du schon gekündigt? Nee. Warum ich so offen drüber rede ist doch kein Geheimnis. Warum soll ich da ein großes Geheimnis drum machen?
Sogar mein Chef auf der Arbeit wo ich aktuell bin weiß, dass ich nach anderen Sachen suche.
Sie wissen auch, dass mir da einiges auf den Keks geht, das ist überhaupt kein Geheimnis und ich bin bei weitem nicht der einzige, der sich umguckt aktuell.
Ich würde mal sagen, bei uns ist es aktuell so, dass von 10 Leuten sich 6 umgucken, vielleicht eher 7.
Also ich weiß von ganz vielen, also wenn die nicht wirklich gegensteuern, muss mich ja vielleicht bald nicht mehr interessieren.
Ich gucke nach was anderem, ich weiß von einem Kollege, den ihr übrigens auch kennt aus Videos von früher, dass der nach was anderem sucht.
Noch ein anderer aus meinem Team weiß ich, dass der was anderes sucht, noch ein anderer aus meinem Team weiß ich, dass der nach was anderem guckt.
Aus unserem Support Team weiß ich, einer guckt nach was anderem, einer ist Ende des Jahres weg, einer geht bald in Rente, einer wandert aus.
Also das wird eng. Der Plan ist, dass ich den Stream angemacht habe, normal hätte ich den Stream gar nicht angemacht.
Das ist der Plan, der Plan ist, dass ich den Stream angemacht habe.
Ich bin froh Leute, ab Donnerstag habe ich endlich Urlaub für das restliche Jahr, dann können wir wieder im Stream bisschen high IQ Zeug machen, irgendwas wo ich mir auch mal Gedanken machen muss vorher.
Wo ich mir vor allem während dem Stream Gedanken machen muss, das kriege ich an den Tagen, wo ich so viel anderes machen muss nicht hin.
Wir bauen wahrscheinlich den neuen Rechner zusammen im Stream, den werde ich Anfang Dezember bestellen.
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher, welches Gehäuse und welche Wasserkühlung, es wird wahrscheinlich Wasserkühlung werden diesmal.
Das bauen wir jetzt zusammen, ja Support ist es nicht, es ist eher 24-7 Monitoring und wie nennt man das überhaupt so?
Operation Center, ich sage immer Support dazu, ist es eigentlich gar nicht.
AMD, nee Intel, Intel 4090, wird teuer, wird der teuerste Rechner den ich je gekauft habe, weil Hardware Preise aktuell.
Kost mich wahrscheinlich irgendwas um 4500 Euro, es wird nicht günstig werden das Teil.
Ich weiß nicht ob es ein Be Quiet Netzteil wird, vielleicht.
Also die letzten Jahre über hatte ich Be Quiet und Seasonic zum größten Teil, nee ich glaube zum größten Teil eigentlich exklusiv.
Ich glaube was anderes hatte ich eigentlich keinem der Rechner in den letzten Jahren über, Seasonic und Be Quiet.
Achso Wasserkühlung, ja das weiß ich auch noch nicht genau welches ich mir da holen soll.
LC Power, ja wenn ich will das das Ding abkackt dann, ich will das Smokers Smoke macht dann LC Power.
Arch Install, nee Windows 11 und VM und da dann Arch Install.
Ich brauch das ja zum Spielen, zum Videos machen und alles mögliche da bringt mir Linux jetzt nicht allzu viel als Main System.
Don't Cry So Much, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Trudge Systems Massive, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wir könnten uns heute mal das.NET das C-Sharp Video angucken, diese 5 Punkte oder 10 Punkte warum C-Sharp Mist ist oder wie das hieß.
Das habe ich ja schon eine Weile aufgeschoben, wir haben gesagt wir gucken das ja zusammen im Stream an.
Wenn die Bank aber nichts machen...
Ne die werden eh zumachen das ist ja Blödsinn, aber die müssen wirklich gucken dass sie da IT technisch die Kurve kriegen wenn jetzt die Leute alle wegrennen.
Äh Pläne für den neuen Monitor?
Nicht wirklich, irgendein OLED Display.
Irgendein OLED Display, ich weiß noch nicht welches.
Was hältst du von Strato?
Mal kurz gucken dass ich nichts übersehen habe.
Was hältst du von Strato? Ich habe einen Server bei Strato.
Ich habe eine VM bei Strato.
Einen, ein Euro Server.
Den habe ich aber schon 2-3 Jahre oder so da funktioniert.
Aber ich kann nicht wirklich viel zu Strato sagen, ich habe bei den nix wirklich jetzt in Benutzung was irgendwie Performance bräuchte oder man irgendwas erkennen kann.
Ich meine so eine billige VM betreiben die nix macht, das kann eigentlich jeder.
Einen Euro Server habe ich ja bei Strato.
Der Job, ja habe ich doch die letzten Male schon ausführlich erzählt, dass ich wahrscheinlich am nächsten Jahr, also dass ich wahrscheinlich den Job wechsle.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein paar Termine offen, noch eine Bewerbung offen, aber also wenn der jetzt mein aktueller Arbeitgeber nicht noch irgendwie was überzeugendes nächste Woche als Angebot hat, dann ist das wohl gelaufen.
Ich meine sie haben die Chance, sie können sagen, die Homeoffice-Thematik wird gelockert und halt auch in einer Art und Weise, dass das irgendwie verlässlich ist.
Also nicht so nach dem Motto, wir überlegen es uns heute so und morgen kann es schon wieder anders sein.
Also wenn sie mir erlauben mehr Homeoffice zu machen und Gehaltstechnisch, das wäre natürlich auch nicht schlecht, wenn sich da noch was tut.
Die pullen uns zurück?
Pullen uns zurück? Ne, ja, ja und ne. Also ich sage gleich was zu, wenn ich im Chat unten bin.
PAP, nice, wollte ich schon immer mal machen. Ich kann sogar ein bisschen Laravel, wenn es um PAP geht.
Der Case Master, Dankeschön für den Sub. Auch die anderen hier oben, Massive Subscriptions.
Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Ja, es wird echt Zeit. Leute, es gibt demnächst neue Emotes. Wir haben welche in Auftrag gegeben. Soll ich euch sagen, welche es gibt?
Moment, boah, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr. Es gibt auf jeden Fall, es gibt auf jeden Fall Wubbedge, das weiß ich.
Ich finde es gar nicht. Ah, wo ist die PN? Neue Emotes.
Warum hat Twitter eigentlich keine gescheite Suche?
Ne, finde ich jetzt nicht. Ich weiß nur, es gibt Wubbedge, Wubcute, also Wubayaya. Willst du es geben? Ich finde es wirklich nicht. Warum hat es keine gescheite Suche?
Es gibt WubFat, WubFat, WubChat, Wubbedge, Wubayaya. Und noch vielleicht ein paar andere, je nachdem. Vielleicht kommen wir ja irgendwie so auf 10 Stück.
Weil es wird mal Zeit. Ich habe irgendwie noch 20 freie Emote-Slots oder sowas und dann kommt nichts rein. Ah ja.
Was hast du für Fristen? 3 Monate. Chat oder Gigachat?
So, also zu dieser Frage. Ja und nein. Also es geht ja um die Homeoffice-Thematik bei uns. Also, während der Corona Monate, Jahre kann man ja fast schon sagen. Was bei uns halt so, es war zum größten Teil Homeoffice für alle. Und man hat gesehen, es hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Ich hatte mittlerweile sogar eine Homeoffice-Regelung da ausgemacht mit einem Tag die Woche im Büro. Wurde gemerkt, ich arbeite ja nur 4 Tage die Woche.
Und man hat sich dann dazu entschieden, das interessiert uns nicht. Sondern es sollen gefälligst wieder alle 2 Tage kommen. Und es interessiert kein, ob man Teilzeit arbeitet oder Vollzeit. Das heißt, ich soll 2 Tage kommen und alle anderen auch.
Sogar Leute, die nur 3 Tage arbeiten, sollen 2 Tage kommen und sowas. Und da habe ich schon gesagt, ja Moment. Ist das mal ernst? Hat sich da mal irgendjemand Gedanken drüber gemacht?
Und naja. Mein letzter Chef hat es ja versucht irgendwie noch halbwegs in die Wege zu leiten, dass das geht. Aber da ist es jetzt ja auch nicht mehr an der Position. Und mein neuer Chef, der probiert es auch. Aber gut, der kann sich da halt der Sache nicht entziehen.
Die wird dann von oben gesagt, es interessiert uns nicht. Leute sollen wieder kommen. Da habe ich mir halt gedacht, gut, dann wird es jetzt mal Zeit nach fast 10 Jahren sich mal umzugucken nach einem anderen Arbeitgeber, der die ganze Homeoffice-Thematik nicht so mal heute so mal morgen so sieht.
Die Sache ist halt die. Ja, das ist typisches Boomer-Management, aber da habt ihr schon recht, Chat. Also, die Sache ist halt die. Man hat gerade in der Corona-Zeit gesehen, dass es wirklich gut funktioniert.
Man feiert sich auf nahezu jeder Veranstaltung, dass es wieder ein super erfolgreiches, das erfolgreichste Jahr und neuer Platinorden verleiht man sich selbst und bla bla bla. Also man feiert sich mega ab.
Aber gibt gleichermaßen zu, das hat wunderbar funktioniert mit Homeoffice, aber man macht es dann halt doch nicht. Zumal man sagen muss, das ist für alle nur das beste.
Ich mache mehr im Homeoffice, habe ich jetzt, seitdem ich da wieder ein paar Mal hin bin, ich habe es gemerkt, also ich mache einfach mehr geschafft im Homeoffice. Ich bin wacher, mir geht es besser, es ist für alle.
Ohne Scheiß, es ist für alle Beteiligten das beste. Und da gibt es wieder so Aussagen dort teilweise so, ja, wir machen das ja auch, weil wir nicht wollen, dass die Leute vereinsamen.
Ja, ist klar, ihr seid so die krassen Menschen, Freunde. Das ist natürlich euer einziges Anliegen. Und letztens hat tatsächlich einer erzählt, als es um die Homeoffice-Thematik ging, dass jetzt viele Leute ja quasi Ende des Jahres abhauen bzw. die Schwierigkeiten haben neue zu finden.
Und ob das nicht auch nochmal an ihrer restriktiven Homeoffice-Regelung liegen könnte. Und da hat einer vom Management gesagt, nein, nein, das ist sogar das Gegenteil der Fall.
Passt mal auf, wie lost und realitätsfremd man da fern da ist. Die haben gesagt, nein, nein, sogar eher das Gegenteil der Fall. Das wäre sogar der Gegenteil der Fall, denn er hat jetzt schon mitbekommen, dass Bewerber gesagt haben, oh, ihr habt aber eine so schöne Kultur hier auf der Arbeit.
Und das war für mich der ausschlaggebende Punkt dorthin zu gehen, dass ihr eine so tolle Office-Kultur habt.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, seriously, hat das wirklich irgendjemand mal gesagt? Also ich höre nur immer unter anderem von meinem Chef der Leute sucht, von dem anderen Team, wo ich da recht eng zusammenarbeite mit, von dem Chef dort. Von allen eigentlich höre ich nur das Gegenteil bei uns.
So nach dem Motto, ah, guck mal, wir haben da einen Bewerber gefunden, aber der meldet sich nie wieder, nachdem er erfahren hat, wie es mit Homeoffice ist.
Das ist zu geil. Mein Chef hat mir erzählt, sowohl der alte als auch der neue beide, haben wir beide erzählt, die hatten Bewerber, Bewerber so und Bewerbung über irgendwelche Personalvermittler und sonstige Sachen.
Und da wurde dann immer gefragt, so nach dem Motto, ja, passt ja alles ganz gut und wunderbar, wollen wir nicht mal vorstellen, wollen wir nicht mal hier jetzt kennenlernen und sowas. Da wurde dann immer gefragt, okay, wie sieht es denn bei Ihnen im Unternehmen aus mit Homeoffice-Regelung?
Und da haben die halt drauf geantwortet, so wie es ist, so nach dem Motto, ja, eigentlich gibt es eine, aber die interessiert keine, jetzt haben die ein bisschen schöner verpackt, ja, eigentlich gibt es eine, aber die wird nur in Corona-Zeiten wirklich benutzt, aktuell ist eher Anwesenheitspflicht.
Und dann hast du nie wieder was von den Bewerbern gehört. Und das habe ich von ganz vielen Leuten gehört, auch in Führungspositionen bei uns, dass sie genau dieses Problem haben.
Und da kommt jetzt einer und erzählt, so nach dem Motto, nein, nein, es wäre genau das Gegenteil, ja, sicherlich, mit Sicherheit, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es bei dem einen oder anderen vielleicht so ist, aber bestimmt nicht, dass wir dadurch jetzt die große Menge an Leuten bekommen, weil wir so eine tolle Office-Kultur haben.
Außerdem, mal ganz im Ernst, also, ich meine, ich arbeite da jetzt lang genug, ich wüsste auch gar nicht, was für eine tolle Office-Kultur wir angeblich hätten.
Oh man, was wir machen, ich probiere nicht einzuschlafen. Ohne Scheiß, ich bin mega kaputt.
Die letzten Streams, die ich gemacht habe, waren eigentlich hauptsächlich, weil ich kaputt war, solange ich nicht mehr online war und ich mir gedacht habe, Leute, ich mache jetzt an, bevor ich noch irgendwas anderes mache.
Können wir ein bisschen schwätzen und ich penne nicht ein, ich kann jetzt nicht um 20.30 Uhr schon einpennen.
Es ist auch Sleepge-Musik, ja, ich weiß.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
200k drinnen.
Du meinst dort, wo ich hinwechsel? Nee. Sind bei dir 100k drinnen? Dann muss ich mich da mal bei euch bewerben.
Cobalt-Mainframe.
Klar, zukunftssicherer Job.
Tja, so ist es halt.
Nee, bin ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich da drauf gestoßen bin.
Captain Peng, danke schön für den Sub.
Musst du dann deine Aktien oder was du dort hast ausbezahlen? Nö.
Muss ich nicht.
Die sind mir.
Das ist mega Sleepge-Musik, man. Kein Wunder, dass ich hier am einpennen bin.
Bei uns haben viele den Vertrag endlich geändert bekommen.
Gerade wegen dem Beweis, das interessiert bei uns aber keinen.
Bei uns sagen sie, ja, das hat ja wunderbar funktioniert während Corona.
Aber wir haben so eine tolle Office-Kultur.
Da sollen die Leute mal wieder anrücken. Also ganz im Ernst.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Ich habe ja schon total viel dazu gesagt, auch die letzten Monate über.
Der Witz ist halt, mein alter Chef gibt mir Recht, dass es besser lief oder gut lief und für alle Beteiligten das Beste ist.
Mein neuer Chef gibt mir Recht.
Der Abteilungsleiter gibt mir nicht wirklich Recht, aber er empfällt auch nichts dagegen ein.
Der darf mir wahrscheinlich nicht Recht geben.
Und was darüber ist, weiß ich nicht.
Aber es kann den dort halt keiner sinnvoll erklären, warum das nicht geht.
Obwohl man ja im Vorfeld gesagt hat, dass es möglich ist.
Das ist ja das Beste.
Während das gut lief in Corona haben die gesagt, hey, jeder, der will, kann eine Homeoffice-Regelung machen.
So mit Formular und unterschreiben und Chef unterschreiben, ihr unterschreibt und dann gilt das.
Aber diese Regelung ist dann nie wirklich in Kraft getreten.
Ich habe das ausgefüllt, habe mich geeinigt mit meinem Chef.
Ich habe es unterschrieben, er hat es unterschrieben, es ist nie was passiert.
Aber das liegt bestimmt auch daran, dass wir so eine gute Office-Kultur haben.
Moin, Schiffs-Kaiser.
Leute, ich penne echt gleich ein.
Wahnsinn, ich muss die Mario Kart Musik ausmachen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, die neuen Emotes kommen wieder von der gleichen.
Nee, wahrscheinlich werden wir nicht anders.
Ohne Scheiß, ich merke jetzt schon, dass ich voll der Mecker-Opa werde in vielen Bereichen.
Was mir so auf den Keks geht, wo ich mir immer denke, alter, mein Opa hätte auch so rumgemeckert.
Und das ist mit 38 schon so schlimm.
Es gibt noch was witziges.
Jetzt chat, weil ich es gerade lese.
Nicht nur Office-Kultur, Office-Kultur, was bei uns auch gerne erzählt wird, dass,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie sie das immer ausdrücken,
dass Menschen am besten mit Menschen arbeiten und deswegen sollen alle auf die Arbeit kommen und sowas.
Alter, das ging die letzten drei Jahre wunderbar und besser und erfolgreicher als vorher.
Aber ja, ja, ist klar.
Also, Chain-Lore macht das nicht.
Das macht die gleiche, die auch schon die anderen Keks-Emotes gemacht hat.
Also, alles, was ihr habt hier mit Wupp, die sind vom Chain-Lore.
Also, die, die, die nicht Chain-Lore sind.
Warum kann ich ihn hier nicht mehr anzeigen lassen?
Hier, ja, das da zum Beispiel, das da, das da, das da, das da, das da.
Und auch die ganzen, und auch die ganzen Kekse, die ich in den Videos verwende.
Das hat die gemacht und die macht jetzt auch die neuen Emotes.
Wobei die gerade ein bisschen andere Probleme hat, als Emotes zu designen.
Kommt nämlich aus der Ukraine.
Aber die ist, glaube ich, gerade irgendwo in irgendeinem anderen Land und macht wieder Emotes.
Twitch-Emotes.
Ja, mehr Kekse gibt es dann.
Und es gibt neue Badges.
Das habe ich auch noch ganz vergessen zu erwähnen.
Es gibt wieder neue Badges.
Da weiß ich aber nicht genau, was da sein, wie es aussehen wird.
Ein Diamant-Keks könnten wir noch machen.
Also, Diamant-Keks.
Wobei wir sowas in der Richtung schon haben, aber das könnte man noch ein bisschen abwandeln.
Ansonsten mal gucken.
Also, wir haben ja schon so alles an Edelmetall und Dingern durch.
Aber da gibt es bestimmt noch was.
Wir könnten ein Ruby-Keks machen.
Gibt es noch ein paar Möglichkeiten.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber es wird auf jeden Fall 4-5 neue Badges geben.
Einfach damit sich...
Ich meine, ein Jahr haben so viele Leute, wir haben teilweise Leute mit 34 Monaten, die haben alle das Gleiche.
Woopslim könnte man tatsächlich auch als Emote machen.
Nein, ich...
Die Suchfunktion auf Twitter, die ich meinte, ist Suchfunktion in Private Messages.
Und die gab es noch nie.
Oder gab es die?
Also, ich habe sie jetzt nicht gefunden.
Die gibt es nicht.
Du kannst Search Direct Messages.
Jaja, du kannst...
Du kannst zu insgesamt Direct Messages suchen.
So nach dem, mit wem du geschrieben hast.
Aber was du nicht machen kannst, ist eine Konversation, wenn du da drinne bist, diese Konversation durchsuchen.
Ja.
Gab es schon eine Rückmeldung nach dem Vorstellungsgespräch?
Ich habe heute...
Also, letzte Woche gab es das schon.
Und heute habe ich nochmal mit denen telefoniert.
Ich werde da wahrscheinlich die nächsten paar Wochen mal hinfahren und mir das angucken.
Damit man sich versteht, ob das alles passt.
Wo Bosscock, alles klar.
Petsi, danke für den Sub.
Verlockendes Angebot.
Ja, vertraglich 100% ganz ehrlich.
Ich hätte da gar keine Schmerzen mit.
Das muss gerade im Vertrag stehen.
Also dort, wo ich jetzt bin.
Ja.
Das wäre auch vollkommen okay, wenn man da die Zusage hat und dann halt das machen kann
und gut ist.
Das wäre absolut in Ordnung.
Das muss nicht im Vertrag unbedingt stehen.
Sofern man sich da drauf einlässt, das zu machen.
Aber das wollte man ja.
Aber hat dann wieder Rückzieher gemacht.
Also insofern.
Im neuen auf jeden Fall, da bin ich mir ja schon einig.
Der neue Job wird nahezu 100% Homeoffice sein.
Vielleicht einmal im Monat dorthin zu irgendwelchen Sprints oder was auch immer.
Aber der Rest wird 100% Homeoffice sein.
Du kommst gerade von der Weihnachtsfeier und es war das erfolgreichste Jahr.
Hey, arbeitest du dort, wo ich auch arbeite?
Wobei unsere Weihnachtsfeier ist erst noch.
Aber ja, es wird immer bei uns auch erzählt.
Das ist das erfolgreichste Jahr oder das beste Jahr aller Zeiten.
Und wir haben uns wieder selbst übertroffen.
Oder ein super erfolgreiches Jahr.
Und solche Dinge.
Ich könnte euch jetzt mal was vorlesen.
Das habe ich gerade vorhin weggeschmissen.
Soll ich euch mal, aber ich kann euch nicht die Details nicht den Namen vorlesen.
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren ein Dankes Brief bekommen von der Geschäftsführung.
Und ich dachte, hey, da springt jetzt vielleicht irgendwas bei raus.
Aber das war im Prinzip nur ein wir sind so toll Brief und alle haben sich furchtbar lieb.
Aber mehr Geld gibt es nicht.
Soll ich jetzt mal vorlesen, aber ich muss das anonymisieren, sodass man halt nichts erkennt.
Da muss ich aber mal kurz in den Papiermüll gucken, weil ich habe vorhin wieder aufgeräumt und da war das Zeug dabei.
Soll ich mal gucken, ob ich das Ding noch finde, das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn wieder gewesen, das Teil.
Kam vor zwei Jahren.
Ich gucke mal schnell, ob ich es finde, warte mal.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich es finde, warte mal.
Kann ich es noch mal zeigen?
Ja, da ist es, da ist es.
Ja, pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Sehr geehrter Herr Max.
Gucken, dass ich da nichts Falsches vorlese jetzt.
Auf diesem Wege möchten wir Ihnen unseren besonderen Dank für Ihre außerordentlichen Einsatz.
Als ich das gelesen habe, habe ich gedacht, jetzt gibt es irgendwas, irgendeinen Bonus oder eine Einmalzahlung.
Ich dachte, ich komme jetzt bei dieser Ankündigung.
So, also, sehr geehrter Herr Max, auf diesem Weg möchten wir Ihnen unseren besonderen Dank für Ihre außerordentlichen Einsatz und hohes Engagement bei der Arbeit aussprechen.
Sie haben rund um die Uhr mit Hochdruck an der Wiederherstellung der Systeme gearbeitet.
Ja, da war was kaputt. Dank Ihrem großartigen Einsatz, das hat der Firma auch richtig Kohle gekostet.
Dass wir da Tag und Nacht am Start waren, hat wahrscheinlich auch Millionen gespart, wenn du so willst.
Egal, Sie haben rund um die Uhr mit Hochdruck an der Wiederherstellung der Systeme gearbeitet.
Dank Ihrem großartigen Einsatz war es uns innerhalb kürzester Zeit möglich, unsere Arbeit wieder aufzunehmen und ohne größere Einschränkungen fortführen zu können.
Wieder hat sich gezeigt, wann war das? Ist schon von zwei oder drei Jahren her.
Ich sage euch, das genaue Datum sage ich euch nicht, weil dann könntet ihr den News nachgucken, welche Bank irgendwelche Systemausfälle hatte.
Also, geht weiter. Achtung.
Wieder hat sich gezeigt, welche eine tolle Gemeinschaft wir sind und wie schlagkräftig wir auch die schwierigsten Situationen gemeinsam meistern.
Bleiben Sie gesund und munter, damit wir auch im nächsten Jahr mit vereinten Kräften neu starten können.
Wir wünschen Ihnen und Ihrer Familie schöne Feiertagezeit sowie Glück und Gesundheit für das kommende Jahr. Herzlichen Dank.
Wahnsinn, oder? Ganz toll.
Als da ein Brief gekommen ist, dachte ich mir so, hey, das gibt jetzt irgendwas. Zumindest mal irgendwie Bonus, Einmalzahlungen, vielleicht extra Urlaubstage, weil man da nachts am... Irgendwas. Irgendwas.
Irgendwas. Nope. Ach ja. Und wisst ihr was das beste war?
Also, wir haben uns ja auch so ein bisschen unseren Unmut geäußert, dass da so gar nichts gekommen ist, obwohl wir da teilweise Nacht und Nebel Aktion gemacht haben.
Und da habe ich dann so durch die Blume gehört von einem unserer Führungskräfte. Ja.
Man soll sich doch jetzt mal nicht beschweren. Wir können froh sein, dass wir danach noch alle unseren Job haben.
Hab ich mir gedacht, wo sind wir denn hier gelandet, Alter?
Ist ja nicht unsere Schuld, dass es kaputt gegangen ist.
Das sind maßgeblich die Managemententscheidungen gewesen, die das dazu geführt haben, dass es kaputt gegangen ist. Können wir noch nichts für.
Also, habe ich auch gedacht, was ist da los, Mensch?
Welcher Manager hat da keine Redundanz eingeplant?
Das war eher so, dass man gesagt hat, wir brauchen das nicht mehr, weil wir ziehen das ja bald in die Cloud um.
Und haben die Leute gesagt, weiß das genau, haben die Leute gesagt, naja, alles schön und gut.
Aber sollte man das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen kontrollierter machen?
Und dann ist mehr oder weniger eins zu eins die Aussage gefallen. Nein.
Probleme durch diesen Umzug nehmen wir bewusst in Kauf.
Tja, dann waren halt die Probleme da.
Aber dann wollte man nichts mehr davon wissen, dass man gesagt hat, man nimmt diese Probleme bewusst in Kauf.
Oh Mann, Leute, ich sag euch.
Oh, was ist das? Was war das Unangenehmste, was du mal auf der Arbeit gefunden hast?
Ach so, also zum Beispiel Dinge auf.
Also Dinge, zum Beispiel andere Rechner von Rechner von Kunden gucke ich mir nicht an.
Hab da leider schon so einiges sehen müssen, was die Welt nicht sehen sollte. Keine Ahnung, damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Es gab auf der Arbeit schon merkwürdige Situationen.
Ja, zum Beispiel genau, zum Beispiel als einer unserer Azubis illegales Filesharing betreiben wollte und solche Dinge.
Aber ach ja, doch eine Sache, eine ganz lustige Geschichte.
Schon eine ganze Weile her.
Es ist wirklich schon, ich kriege es, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie es überhaupt zu dieser E-Mail gekommen ist.
Ich kann es euch nur noch so grob erzählen.
Irgendwann waren auch mal kurz vor Weihnachten Wartungsarbeiten.
Das weiß ich noch. Das war irgendwie kurz vor Weihnachten und auch irgendwelche Wartungsarbeiten nachts.
Und irgendwas war da mit Salzstreuer.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was es mit Salz oder mit Salz oder mit Salzstreuern zu tun hatte.
Irgendeiner hat was von Salzstreuern geschrieben. Zumindest daraufhin hat dann einer eine Mail geschrieben,
dass die Wartungsarbeiten super erfolgreich waren.
Und dann stand in der Mail irgendwie so irgendwas drinne mit, irgendwas mit Salzstreuer.
Und der hat halt ein Foto rein gemacht von einem Salzstreuer.
Es war halt so ein Soft-Porno-Bild.
Halt von einer Frau mit einem Salzstreuer.
Ihr könnt es euch vorstellen.
Das Problem war, der hat dieses Bild leider für ihn an den falschen Verteiler geschickt.
Also erstens muss man schon ganz schön blöd sein, dass man sowas auf der Arbeit überhaupt rumschickt.
Irgendwelche Soft-Porno-Bildchen.
Wäre das nur in diesem kleinen Mail-Verteiler geblieben,
dann hätte man sich vielleicht mal angeguckt und gedacht, weird champ, aber es wäre nichts passiert.
Das Salzstreuer-Bild, ja.
Aber nachdem dieser Mail aus Versehen an den großen Verteiler geschrieben wurde,
wo unter anderem Leute aus, weiß nicht ob es aus dem Vorstand oder so sind,
ich weiß nicht, ob es damals schon Vorstand war oder ob das zumindest Leute aus dem höheren Management dabei waren,
unter anderem auch ein paar Frauen, fanden die das überhaupt nicht lustig.
Und von dem Kerl habe ich nie wieder was gehört.
Ich glaube, das hat sich ganz schnell erledigt danach.
Muss da auch schon richtig blöd sein, oder?
Muss doch schon richtig blöd sein.
Erstens, wer kommt auf die bescheuerte Idee und verschickt überhaupt in irgendwelchen Arbeits-Mailing-Verteilern oder Teams-Channels Soft-Porn-Bilder?
Und dann achtet er noch nicht mal auf den Fall, also das ist doppelt bescheuert.
Also erstens, warum verschickt man überhaupt solche Bilder?
Und zweitens, warum verschickt er das auch noch an den falschen Verteiler?
Also, naja.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Da hast du voll und ganz recht, es kann tatsächlich sein, dass das gesagt wurde,
aber der Bewerber wollte halt einfach einen guten Eindruck machen.
Klar, kann ich dem jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird es wirklich so gewesen sein.
Und ansonsten, was war noch unangenehm?
Was habe ich noch unangenehmes gefunden?
Geht ja nicht um unangenehme Erlebnisse, sondern um was ich unangenehmes gefunden habe oder gesehen habe.
Fällt mir jetzt eigentlich nichts ein.
Was wüsst ihr, dass wir mal einen Case Modded Server mit RGB-Beleuchtung hatten im Rechenzentrum?
Wusste ich auch nicht, bis ich den mal ausgebaut habe und aufgemacht habe.
Ja, gut, dann habe ich das schon erzählt.
Ja, wir hatten einen Case Modded Server mit RGB-Beleuchtung drin.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wer und warum das da eingebaut wurde.
Habe ich schon ein Video erzählt? Ja, kann sein.
Ne, wie gesagt, muss ich nicht.
Wenn du viel meckerst in der IT, dann ist es Zeit Architekt zu reden.
Ah, weiß man ab dann, wenn es soweit ist.
Dann müssten aber gefühlt eigentlich ganz schön viele Architekten unterwegs sein.
Weil die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, meckern eigentlich den halben Tag.
Limits, danke für den Sub. Carlson, danke. 35 Monate Subscriptions hier. Dankeschön, Leute.
So, wir gucken uns gleich noch das C-Sharp-Video an. Mehr bin ich heute, glaube ich, nicht dazu in der Stande.
Ich verspreche euch aber, Leute, könnt ihr jetzt klippen und mir zeigen, soll es nicht so sein.
Ich verspreche euch, dass wir im Dezember quasi ab der nächsten Woche startend wieder ordentliche Streams machen.
Da bin ich nicht so im Arsch.
Wir machen wieder Streams, da programmieren wir wieder Zeug, da basteln wir wieder Kram
und gucken uns mal irgendwelche interessanten Sachen an. Aktuell kriege ich es einfach nicht auf die Reihe.
Aber ich hatte euch ja mal vor einer Weile gefragt, was ist euch lieber, müder Stream oder gar kein Stream?
Und da war die überwiegende, also die weit überwiegende Zahl der Leute hat gesagt, besser müder Stream als gar kein Stream.
Der CPM muss ballern.
Ich schalte kaum Werbung auf Twitch, ich verdiene da eh nix. Also das Einzige, wo ich bei Twitch ein bisschen was verdiene, sind die Subs.
Also ganz im Ernst, ihr könnt Adblocker einschalten, ist mir egal.
Aber ich freue mich über jeden Sub und mit Prime kann man das ja auch relativ einfach machen, kostet einen ja nichts.
Kann ich jetzt noch mal sagen, also wer seinen Prime Sub nichts ausgibt, der überweist quasi Besos nochmal 2,50 im Monat.
Also wenn ihr Prime habt und verbunden habt, dann haut euren Prime Sub irgendwo rein.
Muss ja auch nicht bei mir sein, irgendwo was ihr gerne guckt.
Aber lasst sie nicht verfallen.
Und gerade bei kleineren Streamern, die freuen sich immer wahnsinnig drüber.
Und gerade wenn es was ist, was euch gefällt, was ihr gerade öfters guckt, dann haut den Prime Sub da rein.
Es ist ein super Gefühl, gerade wie gesagt, gerade auch bei kleineren Streamern, da weiß ich, die auch schon von vielen Leuten gehört.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der Größte jetzt auf Twitch, ja.
Aber ich hab's schon von Leuten gehört, die sonst irgendwie 5-10 Zuschauer haben.
Die freuen sich immer wahnsinnig über Follows und über Prime Subs.
Wisst ihr, worüber ich mich freue? Wenn ich auf GitHub Sterne kriege auf mein Repo.
Ich meine, ich freue mich über Prime Subs und Abos auf YouTube und so.
Auch klar, keine Frage.
Ich freue mich aber auch auf GitHub Sterne, das heißt, wer auf GitHub ist und irgendwas.
Dankeschön, Leute. Das funktioniert doch immer hier, die Ansprache.
SirPandi und Kenjin, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wer auf GitHub unterwegs ist und ein Elektroauto hat,
nämlich einen Fiat, einen Jeep, einen Ramtruck, einen Dodge oder einen Alfa Romeo
und mal versuchen möchte, sein Auto in sein Smart Home zu integrieren,
kann mein Home Assistant Addon ausprobieren.
Und wenn es euch gefällt, dann könnt ihr das Repo ja starren.
Moin, Patrick.
Für Ferrari gibt es wahrscheinlich auch solche Sachen, aber nicht in meinem Addon.
Mein Addon ist nur für Uconnect.
Und Uconnect hat Chrysler, Fiat, Alfa Romeo, Dodge, Ram, sonst was.
Aber Chrysler ist so oldschool, die haben kein neues Uconnect.
Damit funktioniert das nicht.
Ja, das wäre was.
Mein ehemaliger Chef war Battlefield-Spieler.
Weiß ich, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Ich habe sogar noch auf irgendeinem USB-Stick ein Heli-Gameplay von meinem alten Chef.
Aus Zeiten, wo ich noch nicht mal ein Chef war.
Irgendwo habe ich den USB-Stick, glaube ich noch.
Und Battlefield 3 Heli gebashed.
Ja, Wub-Bahn könnte man auch als Immort machen.
Hast du schon lange in deiner GitHub-Star-Liste?
Pog.
Oh ja, das kenne ich.
Wie gesagt, da werde ich schon Wert drauf legen.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das ist ja aktuell dort, wo ich bin, auch so.
Da hat man auch erst gesagt, es geht.
Und dann hat man wieder Rückzieher gemacht.
Und ja, und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Das ist auch so, ja.
Bei uns gibt es auch, bei uns gibt es auch Bonus.
Inflationsausgleich Bonus.
Weiß nicht genau, wie viel und wann, aber gibt es bei uns auch.
Es gibt so viele Vermutungen, bei welcher Bank ich bin.
Ich habe schon alles gehört.
ING, Deutsche Bank angeblich, Telekom.
Letztens hat einer erzählt, er weiß genau,
dass ich bei der Telekom gearbeitet habe früher,
weil er hat mit mir zusammen die Ausbildung gemacht.
Leute, ihr habt alle keine Ahnung.
Oder vielleicht doch.
Und ich tue jetzt nur so, man weiß es nicht.
Karlsson, danke schön für den Zapp.
Hast du irgendwelche Angebote, auf die du beim Black Friday hoffst?
Ja, ich habe geguckt, ob es iPhones günstiger gibt,
aber bei Black Friday bei Amazon gibt es nur iPhones
der letzten Generation, der vorletzten Generation
für den Preis der aktuellen Generation.
Ich habe wirklich beim Black Friday Deal ein iPhone 12 Pro gesehen
für 1.250 Euro.
Das ist das Gleiche, was das 14er Pro kostet,
wo man sich so denkt, was ist das?
Ach so, ja, und natürlich minus 13 Prozent laut Prime.
Minus 13 Prozent.
Wo genau ist da jetzt der Deal?
Schlafende Kollegen auf dem Klo.
Oh ja, da erinnere ich mich auch an solche ein paar Sachen.
Schlafende Kollegen auf dem Klo hatten wir auch.
Und Azubis, denen das iPhone ins Klo gefallen ist.
Das war auch geil.
Das habe ich euch aber schon in einem Video erzählt,
wo unser Spezialazubi uns ganz aufgelöst im Gang entgegengekommen ist
und er meinte, ihm ist das Telefon gerade ins Klo gefallen.
Tja, da musste dann halt rausgeangelt werden.
Was willst du machen, ja?
Aber schlafende Kollegen auf dem Klo, ja, da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Da hatten wir auch welche.
Nachmittags schnarche ich ja auf dem Klo.
Wir hatten mal jemand, ich weiß auch, wer es ist,
aber der weiß nicht, wo ich arbeite und ich auch keinen Namen nenne,
aber ich weiß mittlerweile, wer es ist.
27, ich weiß keine Ahnung, wie man das ausspricht.
Man könnte es auch Aofik nennen.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht so gedacht.
Aber danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Wir hatten auch mal einen Kollegen, der hat immer mittags gepennt auf dem Klo.
So irgendwie 14 Uhr rum.
Der hat immer geschnarcht mittags auf dem Klo.
Der ist aufs Klo mittags und hat eine halbe Stunde 45 Minuten gepennt.
Oder länger, je nachdem.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, was es war
und ich weiß, dass der privat viel Stress hatte.
Der hat, glaube ich, 3, 4 oder 5 Kinder.
Die Frau hat den ganzen Tag rumgeschrien.
Der war froh, dass er auf die Arbeit gehen konnte
und da mal eine Runde pennen.
Während der Arbeitszeit am Mittag 14 Uhr ist er aufs Klo
und hat eine Stunde gepennt.
Ich bin gerade krank und in der Probezeit.
Zweiter Monat.
Ich bin bis Freitag krankgeschrieben.
Was soll ich machen in deiner Hinsicht?
Äh, wie?
Was du machen sollst?
Daheimbleiben?
Wenn du krankgeschrieben bist?
Ich meine, theoretisch, wenn es dir besser geht.
Du musst nicht daheimbleiben, wenn du krankgeschrieben bist.
Aber ich würde daheimbleiben.
Gutes.
Kennst du eine gute Google Analytics Alternative?
Ja, kenne ich.
Also, lightweight.
Es gibt so Sachen wie, früher gab es PIVIC.
Das heißt nicht mal PIVIC.
Wie heißt denn das jetzt?
Matomo.
Genau, Matomo.
Aber was ich ganz gut finde, ist das hier.
Das ist das volle Programm hier.
Man kann es übertreiben.
Aber für so eine kleine, einfach nur ein bisschen tracken.
Wer kommt denn da so rein?
Finde ich das hier relativ gut.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Ja, wieder so ein typisches Projekt, was vielleicht mal ein paar Screenshots hätte, hätte drauf
machen sollen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Chat, das stimmt nicht.
Du darfst arbeiten, wenn du krankgeschrieben bist und dich besser fühlst.
Das ist ein Gerücht, dass das nicht geht und dass es Versicherungsprobleme gibt.
Haben die hier vielleicht ein paar Bilder?
Ja, genau, so sieht das aus.
Coq hat ein bisschen was von Google Analytics, kann natürlich nicht so viel.
Ist aber deutlich leichtgewichtiger als Google Analytics.
Und DSGVO sicher.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Wisst ihr, gibt es auch was lustiges zu tun?
Wir hatten mal ein paar Notfallpläne, so nach dem Motto Terroranschlag, Haus brennt, Rechenzentrum
stürzt ein und solche Dinge.
Wir hatten ein paar Notfallpläne und unter anderem im Notfall, wisst ihr was passieren
sollte?
Von der Idee her war es so, wir hatten einen Hauptstandort in Frankfurt, wir hätten aber
auch die Möglichkeit gehabt relativ schnell in einem Backup Standort das Ganze zu betreiben.
Netzwerktechnisch wäre das dann einfach umgeroutet worden und alles wäre gut gewesen.
Aber es gab halt manche Systeme, die liefen halt nur an dem einen Standort richtig.
Und jetzt kommt der Witz, was heißt der Witz?
Es ist kein Witz, es war wirklich so.
In diesem Plan gab es eine Risikomatrix, sowas haben wir auch.
In dem Plan gab es einen Punkt für spezielle Server, dass man ins Rechenzentrum gehen soll
und die Festplatten ausbauen.
Und das hat keiner hinterfragt bei einem Notfallplan.
Hab ich mich damals auch schon gefragt, hä?
Alter, das sind Notfallpläne für Feuer und Haus stürzt ein und was auch immer.
Meint ihr ernsthaft, da geht noch jemand, wenn es brennt oder irgendwie sonst was ist,
da jemand ins Rechenzentrum baut die Festplatten auf und trägt sie rüber?
Stand da wirklich drin?
Festplatten ausbauen.
Da denke ich mir immer, wenn da sowas drin steht, da kann man es nicht ernst nehmen, oder?
Wahrscheinlich, ohne Mist, wir haben so ein paar Leute bei uns, die sind so richtig hardcore,
was so Liebe zur Firma angeht, die werden wahrscheinlich auch ins brennende Rechenzentrum
rein gelaufen, wobei in der IT gibt es das weniger bei uns.
Aber die werden wahrscheinlich auch ins brennende Rechenzentrum rein mal Platten ausgebaut.
Aber immerhin, die hätten dann zu Weihnachten bestimmt auch so einen Dankesbrief gekriegt.
Also wie gesagt, wenn du dich wieder fit fühlst, kannst du ja durchaus wieder arbeiten.
Aber ich würde ehrlich gesagt warten, bis ich nicht mehr krankgeschrieben bin und dann
einfach ganz normal wieder anfangen.
Hast du dir Gedanken, dass du jetzt nicht gut ankommst, oder was ist dahinter Gedanke?
Silvercross fragt, ich würde gerne mein erstes kleines Projekt mit dem, ich glaube das wird
heute mit dem Video, ich muss jetzt mal langsam hier mit dem Chat rankommen, sonst können
wir uns das.NET Video, das ist die Sharp Video heute nicht mal angucken.
Vor allem das Video geht ja auch irgendwie eine halbe Stunde oder so.
Und ihr wisst, wenn ich eine halbe Stunde Video gucke, bin ich noch mal eine halbe Stunde
am Schwätzen dabei.
Ich würde gerne mein erstes kleines Projekt mit einem ESP32 und Home Assistant umsetzen,
also schon mal eine gute Kombination.
Und hab an die Xiaomi Mi Smart Body Composition 2 gehabt, ja wunderbar.
Du hast das doch auch, muss ich da irgendwas beachten?
Und kann man den ESP32 auch irgendwie einfach über einen Akku und eine Batterie betreiben?
Also das sind ja mehrere Fragen.
Die erste Frage, ich würde überhaupt in Frage stellen, ob es sinnvoll ist für das Auslesen
dieser Scale noch was eigenes zu bauen, weil mittlerweile gibt es Home Assistant Plutus
Unterstützung und Home Assistant Plutus Proxy, die glaube ich auch diese Mi Scale mittlerweile
unterstützen.
Guckt ihr mal an, es gibt seit 2-3 Home Assistant Versionen Plutus Proxys.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen, das muss ein Supporter der Controller sein.
Darauf flasht man dann, was vom Home Assistant Projekt bereitgestellt wird.
Und das ist quasi so eine kleine Bridge, so als hättest du einen USB Stick mit Plutus
an dem Home Assistant Server hängen, nur dass quasi die Antenne von dem ESP benutzt wird.
Guckt mal nach Plutus Bridge für Home Assistant.
Das ist neu, das gibt es seit 2-3 Versionen und ich glaube die unterstützen mittlerweile
auch die Mi Scales.
Also ich würde das gar nicht selbst programmieren mehr.
So und die nächste Frage ist, ob du darauf was beachten musst.
Ja, wenn du sowas selbst beachten musst, musst du darauf achten, dass du nach Möglichkeiten
nicht aktiv deine Plutus Geräte abfragst, sondern lauscht, wenn was reinkommt.
Weil aktiv abfragen, verbraucht unglaublich viel Batterie, passiv lauschen nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen eine Herausforderung am ESP32, weil du musst Plutus und WLAN gleichzeitig
aktiv haben.
Das geht eigentlich so ohne weiteres gar nicht, weil es die gleiche Antenne verwendet.
Das heißt, du musst immer mal zwischendurch umschalten.
Das ist ganz interessant zu machen, das funktioniert aber nicht so einfach.
Und die nächste Frage ist, kann man den ESP32 auch einfach über Akku oder eine Batterie
betreiben?
Kannst du, aber für den Anwendungsfall geht das nicht, weil du musst den aktiv lauschen
haben, wenn gerade eine passive Meldung von der Waage kommt.
Also das Ding muss permanent Plutus lauschen, da ist mit Standby im Akkubetrieb nichts.
Möchtest du zum Beispiel einen Sensor für Temperatur oder so betreiben, dann kannst
du das mit einem Akku oder einer Batterie machen, aber auch nicht mit einem normalen
ESP32 Board, weil der ESP32 selber, der verbraucht zwar nicht allzu viel Strom, aber die Boards
sind nicht für Low Power ausgelegt.
Die Boards haben beispielsweise USB, 5V Spannungswandler drauf und sowas, die immer aktiv sind, egal
ob Sleep, nicht Sleep, sonst was.
Dementsprechend laufen die Dinger vielleicht, selbst mit einem fetten Akku, vielleicht 1-2
Wochen und dann ist es vorbei.
Das bringt nichts.
Was du brauchst, wenn du ein Akku Projekt machen willst, ist, du brauchst ein Board,
zum Beispiel sowas, du brauchst ein Board, was für Low Power Betrieb ausgelegt ist.
Also das Ding verbraucht im Deep Sleep ungefähr 10 Mikroampere, nicht Milliampere, Mikroampere.
Und das läuft, wenn du nicht oft aufwachst am Tag, sagen wir mal, du machst am Tag 2-3
Temperaturmessungen und nur wenn die Temperatur mehr als ein halbes Grad zur letzten Messung
abweicht, schickst du überhaupt ein Wifi-Message, dann kannst du das Ding ja quasi 99% im Deep
Sleep haben und erwacht ja bloß für ein paar Millisekunden am Tag auf.
Da kannst du es theoretisch 3-4 Jahre an einem 1200 Milliampere Stunden Akku laufen lassen.
Das muss dann aber auch dafür ausgelegt sein und muss dafür halt auch das passende Board
sein.
Sonst funzt das nicht.
Nee, ist es tatsächlich oft nicht.
Wobei, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, Office, die Office kann ich nicht angucken, weder
das Original, noch die US-Variante, noch die deutsche Variante.
Die deutsche Variante geht noch am ehesten.
Das liegt einfach daran, dass es so unangenehm und cringe zu gucken, das ist einfach nicht
die richtige Sendung für mich.
Aber das Meme benutzen ja auch und das hat zwar unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Ja, ich glaube die Mail habe ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube die Mail, die liegt noch, wenn überhaupt, in meinem alten Lotus Notes Archiv
auf der Arbeit.
Wie viel Energie kriegt man aus Wi-Fi Wellen, könnte man dann den ESP damit betreiben?
Nö.
Du kannst höchstens so einen Charger kaufen, diese wireless Charging-Dinger.
Da kannst du ihn dran anschließen, aber die Dinger haben ja halt auch, die sind halt nicht
wirklich wireless, also nicht wirklich weit wireless.
Eins, zwei Zentimeter, das bringt dir ja nichts.
Wenn überhaupt, zwei Zentimeter schon zu weit für die meisten Telefon-Charger, das
muss ja direkt drauf liegen, das hat bloß den Vorteil, dass du kein Kabel einstecken
musst.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Es gibt andere Möglichkeiten seinen ESP32 autark zu betreiben.
Wenn du wirklich so eine ultra-low-Power-Kiste hast, noch mit Akku, kannst du zum Beispiel
ein kleines Solar-Panel dran machen.
Aber das ist auch alles nicht schön.
Ich würde lieber das so sparsam bauen, dass es drei, vier Jahre hält, der Akku.
Geht halt nur bei bestimmten Anwendungsszenarien und dann halt einmal aufladen.
Es gibt einen großen Storage-Hersteller, der Enterprise aber mit RGB-Frontblende verkauft.
Ja?
Ja, sieht cool aus, oder?
Wirklich RGB oder einfach nur, also hat das auch irgendeinen Sinn, so Temperatur-Anzeigen
oder sowas?
Neun plus, geil, wandern, ich war heute wieder zwei Stunden wandern.
Leute, ich war heute wieder mega abgefuckt von DPD, Leute.
Unglaublich, ey.
Warte mal.
Nitter.
Nein, nein, ich will, ich will, ich will nicht hin, ich will auf, ich will auf Nitter.
Wie?
Wo ist es denn?
Find ich nicht.
Ja, da.
Ja.
Hm?
Findet's nicht.
Ja.
Guck mal.
Also, ich hab'n Trocker, ich hab'n Trocker bestellt bei Amazon, es wurde da falsche
Trocker geliefert.
Also, was hab ich gemacht?
Ich bin über diesen Riture-Zurücksenden-Assistent von Amazon gegangen und hab'n mir das Etikett
ausgedruckt.
Dann hab' ich das heute Morgen ins Auto geladen, 25 Kilo Paket mit Trocker, bin zum DPD-Shop
gefahren und da meinte diese äußerst unfreundliche Bedienung von DPD, das wäre zu schwer.
Das können Sie hier nicht annehmen, das ist zu schwer.
Hab' ich ihr gesagt, aber Amazon steht aber, man soll es in den Paket-Shop bringen.
Das ist egal, das kann Sie nicht annehmen.
Bei Amazon selbst steht nichts zu diesem Fall.
Auf der Homepage von DPD kann man eine Abholung beantragen.
Das Problem ist nur, die Abholung kann man nicht beantragen für Riturenpakete, sondern
nur, wenn man selbst es bezahlt.
Also, wenn ich quasi selbst jetzt ein Versandetikett drucken will, Versand bezahle, 25 Euro, dann
kann ich den zum Abholen bestellen.
So, also was soll ich denn jetzt machen?
Darauf antwortet mir DPD, ja gut, das muss von Amazon in Auftrag gegeben werden.
Dann hab' ich ein bisschen geflamed, dass mich das übelst abfuckt.
Zumindest hat dann Amazon tatsächlich noch geantwortet.
Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein Link?
Ah, geht nicht auf, okay.
Return, so super.
So, dann hat sich Amazon gemeldet, aber ich hatte dann Glück im Unglück.
Als ich fertig wandern war, als ich meine zwei Stunden Runde fertig hatte, ist folgendes
passiert.
Ich fahr' zurück und seh' direkt zwei Minuten bevor ich am Auto bin, seh' ich schon die
Straße, da steht ein DPD-Auto.
Und quasi als ich am Auto bin, oder fast am Auto bin, fährt das DPD-Auto los.
Also ins Auto rein, geguckt, wo fährt das Auto lang, er hält, ausgestiegen auf den Fahrer
gewartet, hab' ich den Fahrer gefragt, ob er das Paket mitnehmen kann.
Jo, er konnte kein Wort Deutsch, außer Paket.
Paket hat er verstanden.
Aber soll mir recht sein.
Dann hat er das Paket gescannt mit seinem Scan-Gerät, hat's ins Auto geschmissen und
abgeht die Post.
Oder die Post nicht, DPD.
Da hatte ich wirklich Glück im Unglück, weil das hat mich schon wieder extrem abgefuckt.
Erst kriegst du den falschen Drucker geschickt und dann musst du dich auch noch darum kümmern,
wie du kriegst den Kram jetzt wieder zurück.
Danke schön, danke für den Sub, Sirpundi.
Ah nee, euch hab ich schon gesehen, aber trotzdem hier.
Massive Subscriptions.
Sollen wir mal gucken, ob irgendjemand mein Githaprojekt gestartet hat?
Siehste, ich muss das öfters zeigen, Leute.
Ich muss es öfters im Stream zeigen.
Krieg ich immer neue Sterne für das Projekt.
Progas.
Oh guck mal, wir haben ein neues Issue, das hab' ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Was haben wir denn?
Plottwist war kein DPD-Boote.
Aus Lachen hab' ich mir auch schon drüber lustig gemacht.
Hab' ich gesagt, vielleicht war das jetzt ein faked DPD-Fahrer,
der einen neuen Drucker jetzt bald daheim stehen hat.
Aber nee, ich hab' in der Sendeverfolgung geguckt, das ist eingegangen und ist jetzt auf dem Weg.
Wir haben ein neues Issue, das kenn' ich noch gar nicht.
Okay, 500e blink.
Do blinking for the neuer 500 work.
Das ist ein deutscher, oder?
Dieses Githap-Issue ist jetzt deutsch.
Ob das Blinken der Lichter bei dem 500e funktioniert?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist zwar das gleiche Auto, was ich habe, aber hab' ich nicht ausprobiert.
Kein Plan.
Okay.
Two sense for optimizing.
What?
Okay, jetzt kann ich ihm nicht folgen.
Ah, der hätte gerne, dass die Sensoren in Home Assistant anders sind.
Das geht nicht, weil ich ja eins zu eins das Jason von Fiat quasi in Home Assistant exportiere.
Und ich gar nicht weiß, wie die Antworten aussehen für alle möglichen Autos.
Das kann ich nicht machen.
Dann geht's ja vielleicht für die Hälfte der Leute nicht mehr.
Lin-Lia-Pnrip-Prime-Sub. Dankeschön.
Lieb?
Lieben?
Ich weiß, dass ich ausbreche, ich bin wirklich unfähig dazu, aber Massive, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Top.
High IQ Subscription.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich weiß, dass das geht.
Aber ich war faul, es wäre umständlicher für mich gewesen, die Url wegzumachen.
Ich hab nämlich die Url schon in der Zwischenablage gehabt und hab das einfach reingepastet ins Comet.
Ich weiß, dass das geht.
Ich war zu faul.
Die Preise von Apple-Produkte sind mehr bloated als JavaScript-Frameworks.
Tja.
Das stimmt.
Seit heute für zwei Tage bei Rebuy gibt's iPhones mit zusätzlichen Prozent.
Ist Rebuy, ist das was Gebrauchtes?
Hört sich so an, ja.
Ja, anscheinend.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ähm, also aktuell verwende ich ja das Handy, was mir die Firma zur Verfügung stellt.
Aber ich brauch ein eigenes, also das wird dann...
Also mein eigenes Handy.
Ah, da hast du Glück gehabt.
Also was wir auch schon geschafft haben, auch was immer mal ganz witzig war,
jemand schon mal einen Server gehabt mit einem Raid 1,
wo das Raid kaputt gegangen ist, bzw. wo eine Platte kaputt gegangen ist.
Wahrscheinlich kommt ihr öfters vor.
Was machst du dann?
Du machst die Platte raus und machst eine neue Platte rein.
Blöd ist jetzt nur, wenn du die falsche Platte raus machst.
Dann ist das Ding halt ziemlich im Arsch.
Ich hab's doch schon gesehen, dass Leute geschafft haben,
die kaputte Platte drin zu lassen, die andere zu tauschen
und tatsächlich die kaputtende Platte auf die neue Platte zu rebuilden.
Also es geht natürlich nur, wenn du neu bootest dann,
aber alles schon gesehen.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, dann hast du wenigstens noch eine funktionierende.
Das hab ich schon öfters gesehen, dass bei einem Raid 1 ausversehen
die funktionierende Platte ausgetauscht wurde.
Normalerweise hast du ja immer ein Lämpchen dran,
was übrigens auch der Vorteil ist von einem ordentlichen Servergehäuse
und ordentlichen Hotswap-Dingern,
dass das angezeigt wird.
Normalerweise hast du ja da, wenn es nicht irgendwas billig zusammengebaut ist,
hast du ein Lämpchen vorne dran, wenn die Platte kaputt ist.
Welche das ist?
Nicht immer, aber zum größten Teil.
Und trotzdem schaffen es Leute, die falsche Platte rauszuziehen.
Kann schon mal passieren.
Also das Schlimmste in der Richtung, was ich mal ausversehen gemacht hab,
ist, ich bin mal mit meiner Jacke hängen geblieben an einem SFP Plus
oder an einem SFP Modul und hab das aus dem Switch rausgezogen.
Ausversehen.
So ein Cisco Chipics.
Wie spricht man den Krams aus?
Chipic, Gibic?
So ein Ding hab ich dann ausversehen rausgezogen,
weil ich mit der Jacke dran hängen geblieben bin.
Also es lief so, ich bin dran vorbei gelaufen, bin hängen geblieben.
Zack war das Modul draußen und ich dachte mir so,
oh shit, es geht bestimmt was kaputt.
Ich hab's in den Switch wieder reingesteckt
und hab keinem gesagt, dass es passiert ist.
Und meint ihr, es hat jemand was gemerkt?
Meint ihr, es ist was passiert?
Nein.
Nix ist passiert.
Ich hab mir nur kurz in die Hose gemacht.
Das weiß ich noch.
Das war auch noch nachts.
Das war damals, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, nachts.
Da waren wir nachts zu zweit im Rechenzentrum
und ich hab ausversehen das Modul rausgezogen von dem Switch.
Nix passiert.
Nee, nicht in falschen Port.
Konntest du nicht machen.
Rausgezogen, ausversehen.
Ich dachte mir so, oh fuck.
Jetzt geht bestimmt gleich irgendwas kaputt.
Ich hab das Ding wieder reingeschoben, alles gut.
Nix passiert.
Keiner was gemerkt.
Und ich hab es auch keinem gesagt.
Hey Max, du hast mich mit dem Spazierengehen
und dem Abnehmen inspiriert.
Da ich aktuell durch die Uni recht wenig Zeit habe,
auch echt unmotiviert bin, im Winter rauszugehen,
habe ich mir ein Laufband fürs Homeoffice geliebt.
Was hältst du davon?
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube Laufband,
also ich kann nur von mir ausgehen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei dir ist.
Aber mir wäre Laufband zu langweilig.
Weil was machst du denn dann?
Fernseh gucken ist langweilig.
YouTube gucken ist auch langweilig,
wenn man sich bewegt dabei.
Also ohne Mist.
Frische Luft und bisschen durchs Grüne laufen
motiviert mich tatsächlich am meisten,
mal zwei Stunden vor die Haustür zu gehen.
Laufband plus VR.
Okay, ja das lass ich mir gefallen.
Dann hast du halt noch ein schweres VR-Hertzeit auf dem Kopf.
Also ich glaube mir wäre das zu langweilig.
Auf dem Laufband da zwei Stunden zu laufen.
Ach Laufband während der Arbeit.
Du meinst so, wie der Linux-Erfinder das macht.
Der hat ja auch ein Laufband an seinem Schreibtisch.
Ja gut, das ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt,
wenn du viel Homeoffice machst und dich quasi
dabei permanent ein bisschen bewegen willst.
Kann man machen, ja.
Weiß ich nicht, was ich davon halte.
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken gemacht.
Wird doch wieder nichts mit dem Video.
Ja, ich sehe es schon kommen, das wird nichts.
Wir fangen aber an zu gucken.
Ich habe ja gesagt, wir gucken uns das
die Sharp Sack Video an.
Alter, wie weit hinten dran bin ich denn
mit dem Chat, bitteschön.
Risikomatrix.
Ja, eine Risikomatrix haben wir auch.
Leute, ich habe mal gewissenhaft unsere Risikomatrix
ausgefüllt, wenn man ein RM auf dem Server macht.
Remove von der Datei.
Ich habe unsere Risikomatrix ausgefüllt.
Das war ganz hohes Risiko.
Weil unsere Risikomatrix steht dann drinnen
so nach dem Motto, existiert ein Rollback-Verfahren.
Ist es ein etablierter Workflow.
Erfolgt es nach dem Vier-Augen-Prinzip.
Da musste ich sagen, realistisch betrachtet,
ich gehe auf den Server und lösche dort mit RM
eine Datei.
Nee, das hat kein Rollback.
Das ist auch nicht Vier-Augen.
Und auch sonst auch nichts.
Und da kam rausgekommen, RM auf ein Log-File
wäre unglaublich hohes Risiko, laut dieser Risikomatrix.
Das habe ich dann mal unseren Change-Manager gefragt.
Da musste er erst lachen.
Und ich meinte, ja gut, aber ist doch ein realistischer Fall.
Und dann habe ich nie wieder was von gehört.
So wie quasi bei fast allen Sachen bei uns,
die nicht in irgendwelche Prozesse oder Abläufe passen.
Dann hörst du nie wieder was von.
Und im Zweifelsfall erzählt dir dann irgendjemand,
ja, das muss man dann mit gesundem Menschenverstand machen.
Und wenn du dann Sachen mit gesundem Menschenverstand machst,
dann heißt das, warum hast du dich nicht an den Prozess gehalten?
Also das ist auch so ein bisschen schizophren irgendwie manchmal.
Baue doch mal eine App, die Time to Read für den Chat ausreicht.
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Chat.
Hi IQ Stream Projekt.
Sind das kritische Daten?
Du meinst, die damals ausgebaut werden sollten,
selbst im Brandfall vom Rechenzentrum?
Ja, es geht so.
Also ich weiß, ein Server davon war für Seminarbuchungen.
Da konnte der Außendienst Seminare buchen.
Wenn die jetzt weg gewesen wären,
wären wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wild gewesen.
Also wirklich wild schon.
Aber im Vergleich zu jemand muss ins brennende Rechenzentrum rein,
eher weniger wild, ja, wenn überhaupt.
Wenn überhaupt einen Tag Homeoffice gibt es da.
Tja.
Nee, die kündigen dich nicht.
Guck mal, die suchen doch.
Die suchen doch.
Hände ringt Leute.
Warum sollten die dich rauswerfen, wenn die mit dir zufrieden sind
und du mal krank bist?
Nein, das wird früher oder später auch öfters mal vorkommen.
Also das, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass sie dich einfach, weil du mal eine Woche krank bist,
rausschmeißen in der Probezeit.
Und es mag sich jetzt doof anhören.
Aber was ist das für ein Scheißladen,
wenn die dich nach einer Woche, wo du krank bist
und auch wirklich krank geschrieben bist,
auch wirklich krank bist, in der Probezeit raus schmeißen?
Wie bescheuert muss man sein?
Also da wären die schon äußerst pepega, ja.
Zumal, dann müssten sie sich ja jemand Neues suchen.
Jemand Neues suchen ist viel teurer.
Nee, die schmeißen dich nicht raus.
Oder sie sind komplett lost und demnächst epleite.
Irgendwie ist es so,
wie man einen gemieteten Server bei Hetzner einrichtet.
Ach so, so einrichtet,
dass er seinen Traffic über das Tor-Netzwerk leitet.
Boah, das kann ich dir aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Dafür habe ich, also ich habe noch nie
einen Route allen Traffic über Tor gemacht.
Ich habe den Tor-Browser schon verwendet.
Ich habe auch schon so böse Hacker-Distributionen
wie Kali Linux verwendet, so Zeug dabei ist.
Aber schick deinen ganzen Traffic über Tor
habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Muss aber gehen,
weil irgendwie müssen diese ganzen Onion-Kisten
ja betrieben werden.
Was ist CAC-WSS-Service bei dir auf GitHub?
Das ist ein Testprojekt,
was wir ganz gerne mal verwenden im Stream,
wenn wir irgendwelche Cloud-Features ausprobieren.
Also bei den Hetzner Streams verwende ich CAC-WSS-Service gerne.
Das ist eine simple.NET-Anwendung,
die CAC-W rotiert.
Also CAC-WSS-Service rotiert das CAC-W-Emote.
Random.
Von 0 bis 360 Grad dazwischen.
Und die kann mittlerweile
sogar im Cluster betrieben werden.
Also du kannst mittlerweile sogar mit Loadbalancer davor
und mehreren Application-Servern den Kram betreiben.
Ist im Prinzip eine kleine Test-Anwendung,
um Cloud-Sachen auszuprobieren.
Wir haben Ansible-Zeug damit schon jede Menge gemacht.
Wir haben Terraform damit ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Wir haben neue Hetzner Flexible-IP-Geschichten
hier mal sponsort gezeigt.
Bietet sich eigentlich an, so eine Mini-Anwendung zu haben,
wenn man was ausprobieren will.
CAC-W.Services ist down, ja.
Die Kisten sind ja auch aus.
Hat hier jemand was Trailer-Park-Boys?
Das sagt mir nix.
Ich kann mich nur noch an die...
Wie hießen diese Typen?
I'm an Island-Boy?
Oh, das war so schlecht.
Die gibt's wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr.
Oh nein, ja, cringe.
Ja, das war richtig cringe.
Hallo Ghost Rider.
Nein, wie gesagt, das hatten wir schon, das geht nicht.
Ja, mit Nachwuchs ist das schwierig.
Da fängt man sich laufend fast ein.
Hast du dich vor zu leaken?
Ja, ich bestell mir einfach eine FFP2-Maske
mit aufgedrucktem Keks und dann machen wir Facecam.
Nur, dass ihr das Face nicht komplett seht, easy.
Oder ich werd V-Tuber, V-Tuber.
Dann machen wir so einen 3D-Keks,
dann kann ich dann hier winken und so
und dann seht ihr unten so einen 3D-Keks.
Massive League.
Ihr seht's so? Ich schon.
Ich hatte es aber auch nicht dabei, ich hatte es im Auto.
Oh.
Ja, ich fand das auch super.
Er hat mich nicht richtig verstanden,
aber er hat dann gefragt, Paket?
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, ich hab einen Paket.
Ich wollte es beim Paketshop abgeben
und dann hat er, glaub ich, so was gesagt wie, wo Paket?
Aber ich hab gesagt, ich hab das Paket im Kofferraum.
Und dann hat er, glaub ich, noch mal gesagt, Paket?
Und dann sind wir zusammen bei mir im Kofferraum
und er hat das Paket gescannt, hat das Paket genommen
und ins Auto gepfeffert. Fertig.
Ich glaub, er hat nur gesagt, Paket? Wo Paket? Paket.
Das waren die einzigen Wörter, die ich von ihm gehört hab.
Paket? Wo Paket? Paket. Fertig.
Wunderbar, hat super funktioniert.
Hat es schon mehrmals, dass das Rebuild dann
die zweite Disk auch kaputt gemacht hat.
Oh ja, das kann ja beim Raid natürlich immer passieren.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich hab's ja hier im Stream schon oft gesagt.
Raid ist eine heimtückische Sache.
Man denkt oftmals, man tut sich damit was Gutes.
Muss es aber nicht zwangsläufig sein.
Gerade Raid 5 ist äußerst heimtückisch.
Bei drei Platten eigentlich schon, aber bei allen
sollte es mehr als drei Platten sein.
Ganz besonders schlimm.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch
in Raid 5 betreibt mit mehr als drei Platten.
Der sollte sich überlegen, das vielleicht nicht so zu machen.
Weil das Problem ist, also Raid 5, die Fachinformatiker
unter uns, die wissen das ja bestimmt.
Raid 5 kann eine Platte kaputt gehen und du verlierst
quasi als Kapazität halt auch nur eine Platte.
Es kann übrigens immer nur eine Platte kaputt gehen.
Auch bei sieben, acht Platten im Raid 5 kann immer
nur eine Platte kaputt gehen.
Weil die das trickreich verteilen über die anderen Platten,
dass es Restored werden kann.
Das bedeutet aber auch, dass jede andere Platte nahezu perfekt
funktionieren muss, damit ein Rebuild von einem Raid 5 funktioniert.
Und wenn man sich mal die Fehlerquoten aktueller Platten anguckt,
die Größe gibt es sogar Calculator im Internet für,
haben wir auch schon gemacht im Stream.
Habe ich heute keinen Bock drauf, haben wir aber schon gemacht.
Wenn man sich die Größe der aktuellen Platten anguckt,
die Fehlerraten der aktuellen Platten anguckt
und wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist,
also wenn man das dann sich ausgerechnet hat, dann guckt,
wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Raid 5 Rebuild
nicht richtig funktioniert und eventuell sogar für zerstörte Daten sorgt,
ist das relativ hoch.
Und wir reden mit relativ hoch hier nicht irgendwie
im einstelligen Prozentbereich, nein, nein.
Wenn ihr Raid 5 betreibt mit großen Platten
und mit 5, 6, 7 Platten, dann ist die Chance höher,
dass euer Rebuild verreckt, als dass es funktioniert.
Also nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass einer Raid 5
mit mehreren Platten im Einsatz hat, das ist nichts.
Raid 6 ist deutlich besser.
Raid 6 dürfen zwei Platten ausfallen, ja.
Raid 6 würde ich tatsächlich relativ ruhig schlafen können
bei Raid 5 nicht.
Also Raid 5 ist, was das angeht, eher keine gute Idee.
Ja, der Chat hat Recht.
Raid eignet sich ja prinzipiell nicht für Backup.
Ich meine, es ist allein schon offensichtlich,
wenn ihr eine Datei löscht, dann ist die weg.
Egal, ob Raid oder nicht.
Ja, ihr löscht aus Versehen die falsche Datei, es ist weg.
Also allein schon daran sieht man, dass es kein Backup ist.
Raid ist dafür da, dass wenn eine Platte
oder wenn Festplatten verrecken, dass das Service weiterläuft.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz willst du ja trotzdem,
dass der Rebuild funktioniert.
Weil was hast du davon, wenn der Service dann weiter da ist
und beim Rebuild kaputt geht?
Kannst du dir das ja auch schenken.
Und dann ist der Rebuild und das Neuaufbau auf jeden Fall länger.
Ja, kann passieren.
Deswegen bin ich überhaupt kein großer Fan mittlerweile
mehr von Raid Controller.
Linux Software Raid beste.
Oder gleich wie die coolen Leute ZFS.
Aber ja, selbstverständlich ein Raid Controller
hat zumindest noch gewissen Mehrwert in fertigen Servern,
weil du dort angezeigt bekommst, welche Festplattendefekte
sind vorne am Frontpanel.
Wobei du es ja nicht im Raid verwenden musst.
Du kannst es ja auch einfach als Sass Adapter verwenden.
Du musst ja die Raid Funktion da nicht benutzen.
ZFS, ja, gibt ja zig Varianten, was du machen kannst.
Kannst du einfach was Besseres als Raid 5 verwenden.
Das ist gut.
Die gebräuchlichten Raid Varianten.
Raid 0, Raid 1, Raid 5 und Raid Shadow Legends.
Das ist so ein bisschen flacher der Witz,
aber irgendwie für voll lustig.
Schade, dass du nicht mehr zockst.
Schade, dass es keine gescheiten Games gibt,
die ich gerne spiele.
Was soll ich spielen?
Battlefield 2042.
Wir spielen morgen.
Morgen spielen wir wahrscheinlich auf dem Stream.
Battlefield 2042, Leute.
Morgen kommt die neue Season.
Battlefield Season.
Die gucken wir uns zusammen an.
Was wäre deiner Meinung nach der beste Step,
um im Beruf weiterzukommen?
Da bin ich eigentlich der Falsche zu fragen.
Ich mache seit 10 Jahren bin ich beim gleichen Laden.
Krasser Karrieregrind sieht anders aus.
Bin nun seit 3 Jahren ausgelernter Fachinformatiker
Systemintegrantin.
Schau gerade, was nun alles möglich ist.
Ja, das ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Schau mal, was möglich ist.
Guck dich um, was es für Jobs gibt.
Guck dich um.
Muss dich ja nicht nur bei dir in der Gegend umgucken.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile dank Homeoffice
fast schon international gucken.
Das ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Die schnellste und steilste Gehaltsentwicklung
bekommst du eindeutig, wenn du öfters den Job wechselst.
Aber das darf man immer nicht vergessen.
Einfach nur sinnlos Job wechseln hat ja an sich jetzt auch,
alleine bringt ja auch nichts.
Du musst dann auch was können, was die Leute gerne haben wollen.
Wie ist das Verhältnis zwischen dir und deinem Chef
eigentlich nach 10 Jahren?
Ich hab nicht den gleichen Chef gehabt 10 Jahre lang.
Ich hatte einige verschiedene.
Ich hab gehört, Twitter sucht Leute, die Gurkenarmee.
Du musst halt auch was können.
Und halt auch am besten in einem Bereich, der gefragt ist.
Es ist fast jeder IT Bereich gefragt, solange es sich einfach
als Windows Assistenten durchgeklickt ist.
Das stimmt natürlich auch, Chat.
Die schnellste Gehaltserhöhung bekommst du, wenn du
als deutscher Bau in der Schweiz einen Job suchst.
Wie ist das eigentlich?
Wenn man in der Schweiz sich einen Job sucht, aber in Deutschland wohnt,
dann ist man ja nicht in Deutschland krankenversichert.
Muss man sich dann privat krankenversichern?
Oder wie ist das? Wie läuft das dann?
Ja, musst du.
Du kannst auch freiwillig gesetzlich versichert sein
und da Beiträge bezahlen.
Wobei das weiß nicht.
Es wird wahrscheinlich echt nichts mit dem Video.
Das kriegen wir heute nicht mehr hin.
Nächsten Stream, Leute. Versprochen.
Nächsten Stream gucken wir das.
Leute, ich habe euch gesagt, heute passiert nichts.
Muss ich keiner beschweren, dass ich quasi 90% der Zeit
den Chat offen habe?
Ich habe euch abstimmen lassen.
Müder Stream oder gar kein Stream?
Und keine Ahnung, 95% haben gesagt, lieber müder Stream
als gar kein Stream.
Aber nächsten Stream gucken wir das Video.
Und wie gesagt, versprochen, ab nächster Woche,
wenn ich Urlaub habe für das restliche Jahr,
machen wir wieder ein bisschen mehr High IQ Zeug im Stream.
Muss mal wieder ein paar Sachen geflasht werden,
muss mal wieder gebastelt werden.
Muss den neuen Rechner zusammenbauen.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Time to read für den Rest des Chats.
Das ist eigentlich eine sehr saumäßig gute Idee.
Ich weiß nur nicht, wie ich mit der App tracken soll,
wo ich gerade beim Lesen bin.
Weil anhand des Scrollens im Browser kann es ja
meinen Chat-Mitschnitt nicht erkennen.
Die Idee finde ich aber ziemlich gut.
Das speichere ich mir tatsächlich sogar mal.
Oje, Leute.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt meinen?
Hier.
Das speichere ich mir tatsächlich mal.
Schieben wir mal wieder hier hin.
Weil ich die Idee wirklich, wirklich gut finde.
Das hat was.
Eigener Client, ja, müsste man dann machen.
Mich hat letztens jemand gefragt im Discord,
ob ich nicht eine Windows-Desktop-App entwickeln könnte.
Und da bin ich zu noobig für.
Bin ich nicht der Beste, der Beste für.
Ich meine, ich kann Windows-Desktop-Apps entwickeln.
Ich habe ja sogar schon mal eine für Hardware-Rat gebaut.
Aber wirklich, wirklich,
advanced Windows-Desktop-Sachen kriege ich nicht.
Kriege ich schon hin, aber habe ich keinen Bock, mich einzuarbeiten.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Der Chat ist 30 Minuten alt.
Habe ich gerade schon erzählt.
Reader bauen geht im Browser mit JavaScript.
Ja gut, da müsste ich einen Browser-Plugin bauen vielleicht.
Browser-Plugin.
Das wäre sogar eine Idee.
Browser-Plugin könnte man machen.
Hä?
War ich hier nicht gerade schon?
Nee, du hast wahrscheinlich oben nochmal gefragt, oder?
Max League gab es vor 10 Jahren schon, das ist richtig.
Ich habe mich schon so oft überall irgendwo gespiegelt.
Ich kann dich nicht aussprechen, aber danke schön für deinen Sub.
Viel Erfolg, mein Codes.
Chainlord Rit-Account.
Ich habe jeden Eindruck, wir sind der einzige Discord-
und Twitch-Channel, wo der Chainlord noch nicht gebannt ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum.
So schlimm ist er noch gar nicht.
Er postet manchmal fragwürdige Urls, aber sogar das hat er sich schon abgewöhnt mittlerweile.
Seit ich ihm erzählt habe im Stream, das nächste Mal wird er gebannt,
wenn er mir so komische Reddit-Urls postet, kam nichts mehr.
Aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht warum.
Chainlord ist so eine Art des Shit-Posters, der nervt mich nicht.
Es gibt andere Leute, die gehen mir extrem auf den Keks,
aber Chainlord geht mir nicht auf den Keks.
Sonst hätte ich ihn wahrscheinlich schon gebannt.
Außerdem hat er ein paar Emotes gemacht.
Was?
Das ist eigentlich ein echt guter Witz.
Den müsste ich mal in irgendeinem Video bringen.
Die gebräuchlichsten Rate-Modi.
Es gibt viele Jobs, welche Vollzeit-Remote anbieten.
Dort, wo ich mich jetzt beworben habe, die haben damit zwar nicht geworben Vollzeit-Remote,
aber das ist halt quasi 99% Homeoffice.
Und ich habe jetzt noch eine andere Bewerbung am Laufen.
Dort ist es tatsächlich komplett Remote.
Und noch mehr Kohle.
Mehr Kohle als jetzt, mehr Kohle als im neuen Job, noch mehr Kohle.
Also wenn das klappt und der Laden mir gefällt,
dann machen wir was anderes, wäre noch besser.
Also mal abwarten.
Ich habe heute telefoniert mit der Personalabteilung,
dort, wo ich Vorstellungsgespräche hatte.
Also ich habe es mir überlegt und so sehen Konditionen und so.
Passt alles, würde ich machen.
Und da hat sie sich super gefreut, so nach dem Motto yeah,
so nach dem Motto können wir gleich unterschreiben.
Da musste ich leider ein bisschen bremse und habe gesagt, ja Moment, Moment.
Ich habe noch eine andere Bewerbung laufen.
Außerdem habe ich noch einen Termin bei uns demnächst,
also 100% zusagen kann ich noch nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich bloß sagen, Konditionen und so passt alles
und wir können jetzt quasi zweites Gespräch machen,
beziehungsweise mal Team kennenlernen oder sowas,
aber 100% zusagen kann ich noch nicht.
Da war sie etwas, ja, enttäuscht schon wieder.
Aber was soll ich machen, ja?
Was soll ich machen?
Ich meine, wenn ich mir seit über 10 Jahren jetzt meinen neuen Job suche,
dann will ich mir auch alles angucken, was es so an Möglichkeiten gibt.
Das stimmt, ja, mache ich aber nicht.
Ich glaube, die würde sich jetzt einfach gefreut,
dass die Stelle besetzt werden kann,
weil du findest jetzt ja auch nicht auf jedem Baum einen Senior.
Ich weiß übrigens, Leute, ihr habt mich auch letztens gefragt,
wie der Job überhaupt heißt.
Ich weiß es jetzt, ich weiß es jetzt.
Senior Linux Engineer ist es.
Hat sie mir noch mal erzählt.
Ich war mir gar nicht mehr so sicher,
ob es jetzt Senior DevOps, Senior Linux Engineer, Senior irgendwas anderes ist.
Senior Linux Engineer bin ich dann.
Hoffentlich Arch Linux, Gentoo, wird alles selbst kompiliert nur noch.
Also ich baue neuen Rechner mit 13.900 K im Dezember.
Ich habe alles in den Ordner geschoben, was auf dem Desktop vorher war.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, aber du bräuchst dich sehr in den Frontend,
dass man sieht, wo man gerade beim Lesen ist oder einen Browser Plugin.
Welche Technologie siehst du im Backend als gut an?
Du kannst dein Backend eigentlich nahezu in allem machen.
.NET, PAP, Python, Node.js, JavaScript, Go.
Du kannst eigentlich nahezu in allem dein Backend machen.
Es ist auch eigentlich alles okay.
Gut, es gibt Leute, die wollen das unbedingt in Rust machen.
Okay.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass Rust vielleicht nicht die beste Sprache für...
Aber gut, jeder wie er will.
Dann ist es wenigstens Blazingly Fast und Written in Rust.
Manche Leute machen das auch in C++.
Weiß nicht, was einen reiten muss, dass man das Backend von der Web-Anwendung
in C++ macht, aber gibt es auch.
C++ muss mich vorstellen, eine Sprache, die in ihrer Standard-Library
heutzutage kein HTTP-Kline dabei hat.
Noch nicht mal Sockets standardisiert dabei hat.
Ansonsten kannst du dein Backend echt in allem machen.
PAP, ohne Mist.
Gibt es jetzt Sockets in C++ tatsächlich?
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich in C++ 2023, was wieder 15 Jahre dauert,
bis es Compiler-Support gibt.
Oder gibt es das jetzt wirklich?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
PAP ist tatsächlich deutlich besser als sein Ruf mittlerweile,
gerade mit solchen Sachen wie Laravel dabei.
Es ist wirklich in Ordnung.
Es wäre jetzt vielleicht nicht meine erste Wahl für einen Backend.
Aber es geht und funktioniert.
Ihr wisst, ich würde es, wenn es nicht dagegen spricht,
wahrscheinlich in C++ doch nicht machen.
Aber wie gesagt, Go, JavaScript, Canal können auch exotischere Sachen sein.
Das ist eigentlich alles okay.
Irgendwann gehe ich mal, es gibt oder es gab doch vor ein paar Jahren
so Seiten, die Twitch-Chats mitgeschnitten haben
und durchsuchbar gemacht haben.
Ich gehe am nächsten Mal auf irgendeine Seite
und suche mal nach dem Chain-Lore
und gucke, wo der überall rumpostet
und was der da so schreibt.
Da stalken wir mal den Chain-Lore.
Und selbst wenn er das jetzt sieht im Stream
und sagt, fuck, ich muss meine Messages löschen,
keine Chance, du kannst in Twitch nachträglich
keine Messages mehr löschen.
Wenn es die Seiten indiziert haben, ist vorbei.
Das ist für immer gespeichert.
Hab mir letzte Woche eine 260 FPS-Kamera erkauft.
What the fuck?
Willst du irgendwie so First-Person-Drone-Racing machen
oder so was?
Ach, um Ballerkennung auf Kickern zu machen.
Real kann ich aber nur 200 FPS weg.
Was denn für eine Auflösung?
Die Auflösung dürfte da das Entscheidende sein,
was wahrscheinlich zu viel wird dann.
Real kann ich aber nur 200 FPS wegspeichern.
Liegt das nun an meinem langsamen Code
oder kommen die advertised FPS nicht wirklich auf die Platte an?
Hat jemand Erfahrung?
Also, ich hab damit keine Erfahrung,
aber du kannst es doch einfach gucken.
Guck, wie schnell du die Sachen weggeschrieben bekommst.
Das kannst du ja...
Die Daten müssen ja durch dein Zeug durchgehen,
dass du das schreibst, ja?
Guck, wie viel du schreibst
oder mach im Zweifelsfall halt irgendwie
ein Monitoring-Tool auf
und guck, wie viel IODO auf der Platte machst.
Also, ich persönlich würde auf das Speichermedium tippen.
Worauf speicherst du denn?
Ich persönlich würde auf das Speichermedium tippen,
weil gerade wenn das quasi nur ausliest und speichert,
ohne zu encoden, ist das kein Ding.
Oder encodest du das?
Wenn du natürlich jetzt 260 FPS encoden willst,
so H.264 und speichern,
dann hast du höchstwahrscheinlich CPU-Probleme.
Warum ist Flexi-Spot so teuer?
Keine Ahnung.
Black Week-Woche haben die doch erst ab 24., oder?
Was sagt denn da mein neues Video zu?
Alter, was werden hier für uralte Sachen empfohlen?
Das wollte ich nicht aufmachen.
Ja, guck mal, steht doch da.
Black Friday Sale bis zu 34% Rabatt.
25.11. bis 28.11.
Ja, oder es ist teurer geworden,
weil mein Sponsoring so teuer war.
Kann natürlich auch sein.
Was gibt es im Weihnachtstream?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Unrun Dead, danke schön für den Sub.
Was wollen wir denn im Weihnachtstream machen?
Cobalt machen wir nicht noch mal.
Ruby, das wäre ja was, was ich gerne machen würde.
Ruby.
C++-Applikation.
Oh, nee.
Windows-Desktop auch noch wahrscheinlich.
Oh, nee, plus nicht.
Ganz im Ernst, C++-Cute ist gar nicht so übel.
Aber ich habe trotzdem keinen Bock.
Placingly Fast and Rust.
Mal gucken.
Hier, Speichere auf Laptop HDD plus Manjaro Auflösung.
Aha, da kommt man der Sache schon näher.
Also, die Auflösung ist relativ klein.
Das dürfte recht easy sein.
Laptop HDD ist schon mal fragwürdig,
ob du da alles drauf weggeschrieben bekommst.
Ich meine, 260 FPS, auch in 640 x 480.
Das wäre schon ein bisschen was.
Und JPEG, das musst du ja quasi komprimieren.
Oder kommen die Bilder von der Kamera schon als JPEG?
Oder encodest du die?
Oder komprimierst du die selbst, CPU-technisch?
Also, da könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass die Laptop-Festplatte Probleme hat.
Und je nachdem, wie du das mit den JPEGs machst, auch die CPU.
Mach doch einfach mal, mach einen Hardtop auf
oder einen D-Stat oder sonst was, während das läuft.
Und guck mal, was da so outtechnisch passiert.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Nope, den Preis-Cham gibt's nicht mehr.
Dann gibt's schon den Jahr nicht mehr oder so.
Aber das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen zu weit weg.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das gut ist.
Wie heißt das?
Nicht Stateless Render?
Library?
Wie nennt sich das?
Also, das ist kein GUI-Framework.
Das ist so eine, wir malen ein paar Kästchen und so auf ein...
Intermediate Mode GUI.
Ja, genau, das heißt das, ja, genau.
Also, mal ist quasi immer alles.
Das ist so für Spiele-Overlays und so ganz nice.
Aber für GUI-Anwendungen, Paint's Champ.
Hey, Leute!
Pünktlich 22 Uhr habe ich den Chat durch.
Wahnsinn.
Also, der Stream heute lässt sich wirklich gut komprimieren.
Ich glaube, ich habe heute nichts anderes offen gehabt
für 99% der Zeit als den Chat.
Aber so muss es auch mal sein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe heute echt in den Seilen gehängt.
Gehogen vom Rechner hier.
Übels kaputt.
Ich bin froh, dass ich jetzt pennen gehen kann.
Gleich ist Bedgetime, ja.
Nächsten Stream, nächsten Stream.
Ja, wenn du eine neue Hardtop-Version hast,
die kann sogar IO.
Hast du eine neue Hardtop-Version?
Neues Hardtop kann auch IO anzeigen.
Oh ja, da muss ich mal gucken.
Vielleicht, vielleicht hole ich da dieses Jahr wieder was.
Oh doch, klaut mir das kein Problem.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was wirklich besser geworden ist.
Ich habe ja vor ein paar Jahren, doch gar nicht so lange her,
auf Twitter auch immer ein bisschen gemeckert,
dass ich nicht richtig pennen kann und so.
Ich habe da teilweise mit Leuten nachts auf Twitter geschrieben und so,
weil ich halt nicht richtig pennen konnte.
Ja, und seit ich immer schön meine zwei Stunden am Tag laufen gehe,
und ich meine laufen, nicht joggen, laufen,
habe ich damit überhaupt keine Probleme.
Damit einfach geratzt.
Wenn du Hardtop, nicht in der aktuellen Version,
destat irgendwas, gibt es ja genug Analyse-Tools
unter Linux für Disk-Usage.
So chat, zwei Minuten Zeit haben wir noch.
Gibt es noch irgendwas wichtiges?
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst die Woche,
oder will noch irgendjemand was wissen?
Gleich ist Bedgetime.
Wie geht es Chico? Chico geht es wunderbar.
Die liegt irgendwo draußen rum.
Keine Ahnung, wo die rumgammelt gerade, aber der geht es gut.
Tja, wenn wir so ein bisschen Bewegung
und gerade so ein bisschen Bewegung an frischer Luft doch ausmachen.
Nach der Ausbildung beim Betrieb bleiben
oder lieber direkt wechseln,
das kann man doch so pauschal nicht beantworten.
Kommt darauf an, wie der Betrieb so drauf ist,
ob es dir auf den Keks geht,
ob du mit dem Angebot nachdenkst,
also wenn sie dich übernehmen, zufrieden bist,
so mit den Aufgaben, ähm, zufrieden bist.
Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen.
Also, wenn es ein Kackladen ist, dann sucht ihr was Neues.
Wenn er taugt und denkst, hey, genau,
wir sammeln noch mal ein paar Jahre Berufserfahrung,
warum nicht, bricht überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Ich bin auch bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb geblieben,
aber nicht so lange.
Also, ich hab die Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht
und war danach, glaube ich,
ich hab letztes Lebenslauf geschrieben,
ich weiß es schon wieder nicht richtig.
Ich war nach der Ausbildung, glaube ich, noch eineinhalb Jahre, glaube,
eineinhalb Jahre bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb.
Hast du den Staubsauger-Roboter in Home Assistant eingebunden?
Ja, hatte ich, aber ich benutze den Staubsauger-Roboter nicht mehr.
Ich benutze aktuell einen ganz simplen klassischen Staubsauger,
den man in die Steckdose steckt.
Der Staubsauger-Roboter, der steht noch im Wohnzimmer
an seiner Ladestation und wurde bestimmt seit einem halben Jahr
oder länger schon nicht mehr benutzt.
Ja, wenn du nicht jeden Tag eine Stunde fahren willst,
das ist ja ein Negativpunkt.
Wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast, was verstehen kann,
gerade mit der Bahn in Kombination.
Wie läuft die Jobsuche?
Hab ich mich, glaube ich, jetzt die letzten zwei Stunden
mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit drüber ausgelassen.
Ich hab heute nochmal mit der neuen Stelle telefoniert.
Wir machen jetzt noch einen weiteren Termin
und schauen das mal vor Ort an, mal gucken, wie das so ist.
Ja, und wenn sich bei der anderen Bewerbung nichts tut
oder da, wo ich jetzt aktuell arbeite,
vielleicht haben die noch irgendwie ein gutes Gegenangebot,
wenn da sich nichts tut, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich da hingehen.
Ich muss ja sagen, die machen einen echt motivierten Eindruck.
Also macht wirklich einen guten Eindruck.
Ich habe da ein gutes Gefühl bei dem, was ich bisher mitbekommen habe.
Ja, geldtechnisch ist okay.
Kann ich mitleben.
Und der Rest drumherum auch.
Mal gucken, wie gesagt, mal gucken,
was bei dem Gespräch mit meinem Chef rauskommt nächste Woche
und was bei der anderen Bewerbung noch rauskommt.
Homeoffice ist für mich das Allerwichtigste.
Natürlich neben Gehalt, aber Homeoffice ist für mich das Allerwichtigste.
Wie viele Mitarbeiter hat die neue Firma?
Ich glaube, über 2000.
Ist auch kein kleiner Laden.
Also wenn ich sage, dass ich das machen will, ist das, naja, gut, safe.
Ich fahre da jetzt erstmal hin und ich gucke mir das nochmal an.
Die wollen auch gucken, ob man sich da persönlich versteht.
Ja, es kann immer noch sein, dass es scheitert,
aber aktuell sieht es so aus, dass wenn ich Ja sage,
dass ich das dann theoretisch gleich unterschreiben könnte.
Was die machen, das ist keine Bank, so viel kann ich sagen.
Mehr erzähle ich aber nicht.
Es ist auch nicht in der Finanzbranche.
Ähm, ja.
Was für eine animische Shirt ziehst du immer zu Bewerbungsgesprächen?
Eindeutig das hier.
Weeps in.
Cute Chat am Start, was sonst?
Es gibt auch was anderes in Frankfurt.
Du wirst lachen.
Ich habe total oft Iron Maiden T-Shirts an.
Oder ein Blind Guardian T-Shirt.
Oder was habe ich sonst noch?
Iron Maiden T-Shirt.
Iron Guardian T-Shirt.
Ed Guy T-Shirt habe ich noch ein uraltes.
Und so ein paar blöde Gaming T-Shirts.
Metallica, uraltes Metallica T-Shirt.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Du hast noch ein Fire Tablet mit Android versehen.
Läuft da der Play Store drauf?
Ja, ja, ja, macht das, macht er.
Habe ich nachinstalliert, Play Store läuft drauf.
Musste man drauf flaschen.
Musste man, wie heißt das?
Micro G-Apps oder sowas?
Das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich besser wie ich.
Wie nennt sich der Kram?
Alternative G-Apps oder sowas?
Open, Open G-Apps.
Open G-Apps, jetzt habe ich es wieder.
So hieß der Kram.
Muss man flaschen.
Oder drauf kopieren und dann
läuft auch der Google Store.
Mit Magenta T-Shirt ist er völlig ein bisschen blöd.
Aber warum nicht?
Taugen die Fire Dinger was?
Die aktuellen Fire Dinger sind gar nicht so schlecht.
Gerade preisleistungsmäßig.
Man kann sie leider nicht mehr flaschen.
Ich glaube, das ist kein Root bekannt aktuell.
Für die aktuellen Fire HD Dinger.
Ich hatte ja noch ein älteres.
Aber die neuen haben noch mehr CPU-Kerne.
Die sollen tatsächlich wirklich gut sein.
Also preisleistungstechnisch.
Nicht gut.
Gesamtskala, aber preisleistungstechnisch.
Sollen die wirklich nicht schlecht sein.
Man kann die halt Deep Loaden immer noch.
Man kann das ein bisschen entschlacken.
Dass beispielsweise nicht permanent im Sperrbildschirm
Amazon Werbung kommt und sowas.
Das kann man noch machen.
Aber ich finde es halt doof, dass man die neuen
nicht mehr flaschen kann.
Am besten ist man kauft sich jetzt ein Fire HD,
lässt es ein Jahr liegen und hofft darauf,
dass es flashbar ist.
Würde ich mich aber nicht drauf verlassen.
Okay Leute.
Wenn ihr mit halbem Sleepge-Stream dabei wart.
Bedgetime.
Heute bin ich wirklich halb eingepennt.
Aber ich sag euch wie es ist.
Ohne Stream und ohne Chat wäre ich wahrscheinlich schon weggepennt.
Geht ihr jetzt auch ins Bett?
Frage. Geht ihr auch jetzt schlafen oder?
Bleibt ihr noch, bleibt ihr noch wach.
Cute Emotes.
Von wem ist das?
Nami-Chan.
Aja ja.
Nee nicht, nicht Nami-Chan.
Nayami-Chan.
Aja ja.
Weeps in.
So ich geh jetzt wirklich pennen.
Wo haben wir im Bett Hörbuch hören einschlafen?
Also auch Bedgetime.
Ja ich guck jetzt noch ein bisschen Stream auf dem Handy.
Und dann penne ich auch.
Boah krass Alter.
Also ich werd morgen Homeoffice machen.
7.30 bis 15.30, 16 Uhr.
16.15 oder so und dann ist Schluss.
Dann ist zwei Stunden.
Zwei Stunden.
Eineinhalb.
Eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden.
Rumlaufen angesagt.
Dann hocke ich mich vor den Rechner und mach vielleicht Stream wieder.
Und dann machen wir irgendwas ordentliches.
Was?
Was auf dem Handy?
Ich lege meinen gesamten Rechner auf dem Bett und schlafe damit.
Was?
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Ja das dachte ich mir auch.
Genau das dachte ich mir auch.
Was?
Egal.
Fertig für heute Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
See you.